wait
how
how did it how how'd you do that
let's serve up some news sunny side up
people magazine just revealed their
sexiest man alive
i don't know if you loved him from
clueless or his cut off jeans and wet
hot american summer or that bushy stash
and anchorman like he is deserving i
love when like because to me sexy is
nice yeah and funny and he's funny yeah
he's funny and
so i keep
listen you can't i keep shaking and ross
matthews is not in here anywhere
you are the sexiest man to me rossi tell
people that
and vogue reports that this time they're
whipping out the old popcorn top um it's
a very stretchy s top it's like an
accordion almost yeah and a very high
like squish factor you can ball it up
throw it in a bag stomping it then put
it back on and it's as good as new
i have one here these you've seen these
right where they're like they're like
this big
and what i always liked about is that
they're so hopeful you know they're like
yeah but i could i could make it work i
could fit on you well i'll take that
challenge thank you very much let me
[Music]
see okay
okay
she's a grower okay
not a shower
[Applause]
[Music]
wait
how
how did it how
how'd you do that
look at it
that's a wait i you know what i feel
like i have a whole new respect for
these tops
glamour magazine reports that bushy
brows had their moment but it's over
and the brow pendulums are gonna swing
the other way back to the skinny olivia
wilde bella hadid and charlie's thereon
they're all working a slim eyebrow um i
have loved a skinny brow myself yes
at one point i had basically one row um
i'm lucky that they grew back yeah
now i have you know bushy ones again
yeah i see i'm i don't know if i can say
this but i'm a fan of them
the full bush yeah i like
don't you know what i mean though like
if it looks like your eyebrows were done
with the ballpoint pen
maybe rethink them you know i think if
you have full of brows you should lean
into it if you have thin brows lean into
that okay yeah fair yeah i'm i yeah
the washington post reports that
scientists have made a huge discovery
female california condors can reproduce
entirely on their own with no help from
a male what now to quote the great annie
letticks and aretha franklin these
condor sisters aren't doing it for
themselves
but
there are some reptiles and snakes and
scorpions that can reproduce asexually
but it's uncommon among birds and
scientists call it parthenogenesis
partheno for virgin and genesis for
birth but the two female condors that
produced the male offspring well they
weren't virgins they had reproduced with
males before and had full access to
fertile males but decided to lay eggs
solo
so they don't they're just like i'm good
dude i don't need you
i mean
good for them but aren't you bored right
the wall street journal reports that the
newest trend in dating is people are
showing up in a first date in sweatpants
and little to no makeup absolutely i am
with you yeah yeah no for sure some say
it's like low-key feels more authentic
quick way to weed people out who don't
love you oh my gosh state okay why do
you love this and can you talk to my
girlfriends who are literally like
the sweats have got to stop you know
because the idea is that if it unless
you're wearing makeup then it means you
didn't try but it's like i did try brush
my teeth i wash my face i put on some
clean deodorant i smell good i put some
perfume on but maybe i don't want to be
dressed up tight and why do i need to
pretend to be somebody else if i'm
trying to get you to date me and i'm
telling you i've had great success when
i just kind of been chill about it and
honestly my mom encouraged me because i
i was talking to her when i went on a
first date like a couple of months ago
and i said you know what do you think
mom like i don't really feel like doing
my makeup i'm trying to let my skin
breathe should i put my contacts in she
said no you like your glasses wear your
glasses you ain't got to do too much you
want to put no makeup on do it let him
see you for who you are best day ahead
[Music]
you